will hopefully open up a few more areas
which we can look out for appropriate
pitches but we must also i believe
enforce
against the illegal or use the word
legal uh um
unauthorized pictures
as well that are popping up around our
district thank you leader thank you
councillor cargill councillor junior
mine was to report from the ovue and
scrutiny committee who asked that
they did not want to delay um the
adoption of the sbd but they had there
was a specific request from them uh to
review how the spd was working in
practice and also delays and with the
county council how that was working in
practice so at an appropriate time we
would like to make sure uh
that that this sbd is doing the the job
that it was intended to do
thank you councillor junaid i'm sure
council of pemberton will take those
points on board
and sorry
that's all right thank you leader good
afternoon everybody um
can i just say to councillor pempton
this is very very welcome document um i
know it's taken a little while to come
forward but i think it's
you know
now that it's arrived it's you know
we're all happy with it we've had to
make the necessary adjustments and if i
can just pick up on councillor cargill's
particular point as the portfolio holder
for enforcement i do wish to reassure
cabinet members that
whilst we have slightly changed the
proposals around the local enforcement
plan i can assure councillor cargill
that we would be taking a very much
robust
view
with regard to unauthorized sites um and
i'm delighted to say that whilst we paid
farewell to ron goodyear who's been
an enforcement
officer with us for 17 years we have
actually welcomed a new member to the
enforcement team who's joined us for
from warwick district council
reginda who is extremely experienced so
that we have
um
reinforced our enforcement team so
your points are well made councillor
cargill but we will be taking a robust
approach to unauthorized sites thank you
chair thank you for that reassurance
counselor parry so the recommendation is
on page 17
so
our council oh sorry our cabinet happy
with the recommendation
thank you members of cabinet moving on
item six draft sustainable homes
sustainable communities housing strategy
for stratford-on-avon district
2021 to 2026 councillor barker
i'll make this one short and sweet as
well um we're proposing that we adopt
the draft sustainable homes etc strategy
um and that this recommendation goes to
council
put plainly the most important reason
that it has to be adopted is that we
have statutory and regulatory housing
obligations that have to be undertaken
and that this wraps them up completely
you will notice i'm just heading to the
action plan
the action plan is live and
we are
looking to as you will
as you will see in
i think 4.4 and 4.5
that this will be we will be um
probably making changes
what those changes are are up for
discussion because of our closer and
closer working with warwick so the aims
remain the same
of supporting communities and building
sustainable affordable homes improving
existing housing and helping people to
live independently and preventing
homelessness and reduce the harm caused
by it
if anybody's got any questions about it
please do ask but otherwise i
would ask that cabinet endorses this
strategy for adoption
thank you
councillor harvey and then councillor
junich
thank you
leader
um
we did have a preliminary discussion
about this paper in fact several
discussions about this paper but i would
like to complement the officers
on the inclusion that
had a request of appendix a which gave
some contextual numbers
um
to the the issue of housing
and i have to say
that the most striking
pair of numbers that took my eye in that
appendix
was the information that the median
income
in the district is 28 thousand and four
pounds
and this is insufficient
to afford
in the private sector to rent a one
bedroom flat
where you would need an income of thirty
one thousand two hundred
that to me says
quite a lot it tells me that we have two
responsibilities
one is to encourage the economy within
the district in order median salaries
rise
and secondly to act
on the on the provision of affordable
housing because if
somebody on average earnings
can't afford a one-bedroom flat in this
district
that to me is a is a
sure sign that we have a
a significant problem so i welcome the
information provided by the by the
officers through that appendix there's
one other substantive point i'd like to
make which is that the paper talks about
um regular reviews
that's a cabinet every six months
i welcome that i would like to know
which months not now but i'd like to i'd
like to have stakes in the ground so i
know
every six months that we're going to
have a chance to review progress and as
far as i'm concerned i don't need a
lengthy document to review
what i need in reference to page 42 is
the paragraph which talks about facts i
would like
the six monthly report to provide
data
about homelessness and progress
the state of the housing waiting list
the need the demand for affordable
houses
the number who are living in poor
quality homes
the number living in fuel poverty
and the number two number of empty
houses in the district
if we have information if we have data
on those six items we are in a good
position to say where our resources are
best placed to best affect
so i commend that to the officers
thank you councillor harvey
uh councillor barker do you wish to
respond to that and then i'll bring in
councillor junior i just wanted to thank
councillor harvey for picking out what i
i agree is the
singularly most important thing that we
have a real gap
between income and affordability of
housing and that is the main thing that
we need to address whether it is via the
housing company and working together
with them
whether it is with charities as we have
done in some places uh whether it is
buying stock and one of the things that
we are talking about
is micro homes
um so that what you're actually offering
whether it's for sale or for rent much
smaller so that people can actually live
sing as single people because that is
you know almost impossible at the moment
and is stopping people from moving not
just physically
but moving um up and upwards and onwards
and so that's what we
i guess we really need to see
that social mobility
counselor junit yes it was a specific
request made out to the
view and scrutiny committee um by myself
to ask that we do uh seek um data asp i
did ask originally for a task and finish
group from over and scrutiny that would
look at all the housing waiting list the
exactly the the questions it could be
done that way or it could be and and i
did talk to the chair done through the
ovum scrutiny committee more generally
as a review but we do need to make sure
that um the this document is is
delivering uh and just um on i certainly
know in ulster that there are lots of
people who are in in work who cannot
afford uh to buy houses and there is
there is there are problems but a couple
of questions if i might um
we have apparently got as of april 2021
2.8 million in a pot that is un
committed
when the council receives money in lieu
of on-site provision of affordable homes
i'm just wondering whether that is um
likely to be considered by the housing
company as as
a bill to rent as a possible way forward
and then there is uh
some
data here about mandatory licensable
homes in multiple occupation in the
district apparently there are 250 of
which 61 have been licensed what of the
implications to the council if the
others are not licensed
or the council is not seen as taking
action what is the position
on that
and then i wondered also whether we
could look at the fuel poverty we've got
700
hundred fifty nine households who are
feel poor uh and how we're addressing
that and then more generally um is it
possible to produce data on specific
wards or would that be um too difficult
to do but it would be useful to know
which wards and which areas have
actually got the particular problems uh
either of um
housing waiting lists a lack of
affordable homes
fuel poverty uh just that we can as
councillors get to grips more with the
data for our own own um
our own areas
uh finally the housing waiting list we
start from a position of
5131 households on the list in november
2020 i really want to be able to see
uh
you know some progress in that and
that's one of the reasons why i
specifically wanted uh some report to
the ovian scrutiny committee at an
appropriate time to make sure that we
are scrutinizing and making sure that
things are being delivered for the
people of this area thank you councillor
mark how do you wish to respond to the
council of pemberton um there
is
coming along the track a root and branch
look at everything we do to do with
housing particularly with the housing
waiting list i can't preempt what is
actually going to happen but i can tell
you that in
warwick district um a
rather more radical approach was taken
to their waiting list and i would say
that
we will be stopping people from applying
at birth just in case they need
a house to retire into which is
sometimes what our housing waiting list
does feel like i kid you not
um
it's because it's
it's the turn it's not it's not that i'm
making a point but
that's what that that is certainly um
one of the issues the other issue is
what we um what we actually
end up building in terms of our
affordability as well in terms of um
overview and scrutiny needing a task and
finish group i think that
potentially i i would resist that from
the point of view that we actually need
to do the work first
um and there's quite a lot of work going
on
um with housing particularly as
there's been you know some huge changes
the head of housing is somebody who
is over on the warwick side at the
moment so we're forming those
relationships and getting the plans
together and actually it's a really
really exciting time so there's loads
going on you can scrutinize that as much
as you like but we are doing stuff
that's the difference
thank you council barca councillor
pemberton then councillor parry then
councillor o'donnell
thank you leader um
it was very much along along the same
lines in the sense that
if what i heard was correct that we're
going to have a set of
data points
reported on each six months which are on
all fours with the data points as far as
i can see that the overview and scrutiny
committee were interested in
i suppose the question then is
do we actually need
to duplicate
that work if those data points are
available to cabinet that are available
to
the overview and scrutiny committee and
that should then
generate
where are we with actions rather than a
task and finished good so i would merely
just suggest that we think about how we
approach that because if we're putting
if we're if we're making the data of or
if our officers are making the data
available which would be the in essence
the same data that appears to be the
sort of subject of a task and finish
group let's let's be smart about it
let's measure
let's take the data and then measure the
progress and then
evaluate through the scrutiny process
whether that progress is
in line with
our our our expectations or not
and and
running alongside that if we're actually
as councillor barker has indicated
looking to have a fundamental
reset for the housing team
that would that
those discussions i i again it just
seems that maybe a bit of sort of it
might be just a bit early and i also
look at
the two of you and thinking to myself
you've got an awful lot on your plate
and perhaps this is more of a
forward work program when we've got a at
least to the point where we've got the
first set of
data numbers off off the back of that
would be my
observation that we then sort of get to
a point where we we hit we hit it once
and hit it together
thank you council of pemberton
councillor parry
thank you leader i just really wanted to
make an observation as someone who has
worked in the professional lettings
industry for the last seven years until
the end of june
where we
test
potential tenants affordability
and then take them through a referencing
agency which is governed by very
specific criteria
and the
matrix for calculating that
is that you take the thousands in other
words say it was 28 000 you times it by
30 that gives a rent an affordability
rent of up to 840
per month
um so and that is um
professional guidance in the lettings
business so therefore someone being able
to afford
um 720 pounds per month would need to be
on a salary of 24
between 23 and 24 would take us
up to that 700
pounds per month i just wanted to make
that observation from a lettings
professional perspective
thank you councillor parry
councillor donald thank you chair um
actually it's just for clarification
um i know that counselor june and i had
spoken about a task and finished group
but i felt having discussed it with uh
mr weeks i discussed it yourself council
pemberton actually a session at scrutiny
with portfolio holders and officers and
an update will be far more useful to us
and a more useful resource both time
wise and
and body wise as it were so we were
looking for regular updates because it
is council barca um indicated a really
exciting time moving forward and also
just thinking about housing i'm not sure
if this is the moment to bring it in we
were talking about um sustainable
housing and fitting in with our green
agenda and it actually asked forget
councillor shentonin to let us know just
how
rigid restrictions are regarding the
green agenda um and whether building
rights and national policies perhaps
hindering us in any way because we need
some stronger guidance because i know
that you're very committed and very
realistic with where you think we're at
with the green agenda and our targets so
that was that was one of the offices
that came out of the discussion around
the housing document as well so really
it was more for attending osc rather
than the task and finished groups i
think would be far more useful for us
thank you
can i just confirm that that was the
conversation i had with the councillor
o'donnell
thank you councillor junior
councillor kettle
i'm very happy very happy to comment i'm
not sure whether this is public because
it did only come back yesterday so i'm
not going to tell you how many unless
someone nods at me and says i can
um but yeah the conversations were had
while i was on holiday because some
things i was prepared to talk about and
afghan refugees were certainly one of
them
and we are getting i think it would be
fair to say considerably more than
perhaps
we might have thought of at the
beginning
um
lisa barker has done a really good job
negotiating it both for how many coming
to warwick district and how many coming
to stratford district and how they're
housed
um and i will be keeping a close eye on
it in fact we've already had before this
challenge
we'd already got
afghan refugees coming
and i have an arrangement to go and
visit a family if they agree to see me
um to just personally find out their
story and understand a bit more about it
so yeah top of by absolutely top of my
pile and we will do everything we can
there are also many many people locally
you will have seen this on the stratford
forum and on others
um who are dying to give stuff
um
and i had another offer from a church
today which was a
wasn't just giving stuff it was you give
us a list of what you actually want and
we'll get it
so there's
quite a lot of good will out there that
we can harness
thank you councillor barker and i would
just say that i thought councillor
kettle's points on the afghan refugees
were extremely well made
so with that the recommendation to
council is on page 41.
[Music]
do i have your agreement to the
recommendation to counsel members of
cabinet
thank you members of cabinet so moving
on
uh capital budget monitoring councillor
harvey
thank you leader
the purpose of this paper is to keep
members informed of the progress made
over the first four months of the year
in undertaking the council's intended
level of capital expenditure this year
table two on page 88 demonstrates the
intention to undertake expenditure of
13.9 million pounds this year
including section 106 projects
taking into account the additional funds
of 2.9 million budgeted for this year
this will result in the balance of the
council's accumulated capital receipts
and grants
being reduced over the year assuming all
capital projects budgeted were to be
delivered as reported on tape in table 1
on page 87
from 5.7 million pounds to 4.4 million
pounds paragraph 1.5 indicates that
capital expenditure of 1.9 million has
already been undertaken by the end of
july in the first four months of the
year therefore the sums spent or
committed amount to 14
of this year's available budget of 13.9
million pounds
appendix 2 on pages 95 to 99 provides
summary information concerning the
various projects yet to be funded
through section 106 agreements
of the grand total of 4.5 million pounds
reported on page 98
some 3.6 million pounds relates to funds
identified for the provision of
affordable housing
the paper also sets out the capital
expenditure implications of the
arrangements entered into with slm for
the management of the district's leisure
services provision
the contract provides for the council to
advance up to four million pounds for
investment in facilities with just over
three millions of pounds of this amount
to be advanced over the first 12 months
of the contract from july 2021
this will be financed initially from the
council's own balances supplemented by
borrowing from the public works loan
board as of when required
turning to the implications of the
refuse collection contract that is
currently the subject of a tendering
process
it's intended that the council will fund
the acquisition of refuse vehicles
required to fulfill this contract
involving an investment of 4.5 million
pounds
the cost of this element of the intended
program will be reflected in the terms
of the contract
the new contract will also involve a
requirement for the provision of a food
caddy to all households at an estimated
cost of up to
0.45 million pounds
this sum represents stratford's funding
requirements for the vehicles the
council is currently taking advice
on the best structure for the financing
of all the new vehicles and will require
either stratford or warwick to fund the
full fleet and recharge the other
authority for the the financing costs
if stratford is the lead authority the
total capital expenditure will be in the
region of 9.5 million pounds
the extra capital charge would be would
be recharged to the other authority to
warwick making this revenue neutral for
the lead authority stratford again the
final decision for this delegate should
be delegated to the head of finances in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for resources
i asked leader therefore first
that the current position on capital
expenditure and income for the period to
the end july 2021 be received
and second
that the terms of the second
recommendation in relation to the
requirement for capital expenditure in
relation to the contract with sml and in
relation to the refuse contract
currently the subject of a tendering
process as set out on page 87
be agreed
the figure for potential investment
should be increased to nine million
pounds to reflect the potential for the
for sdc
to be the lead authority for the
acquisition of the vehicles with the
final decision delegated to head of
finances in consultation
with the whole policy of peggy pardon in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for resources
thank you leader
thank you
councillor harvey councillor junaid
yes i was i was surprised at the the
cost of the uh food caddies though i
support the idea of collecting food
separately but i was surprised at uh
0.45 million um but i just wondered
whether there would be any government
grant
to support this because i understand
that
the waste strategy the government waste
strategy is certainly the original
government weight strategy i'm not sure
we've had the updated one yet
was certainly indicating that it was
going to be requirement from government
and therefore i would have
i would have hoped and supposed that
they would then consider uh helping with
the the cost of it
mr brooklyn do you wish to respond
before i before i've been finished could
i also confirm uh that the the the play
area that is listed in here uh hopkins
precinct is commencing the week
beginning
13th of september to be finished by the
8th of october and thank you to all
officers concerned
thank you mr buckland and then council
of pemberton thank you chairman and if
they've already gone funding from
government would absolutely take
advantage of that first council of
junior unfortunately until it is a new
burden we haven't had the new burdens
funding that would come with that and
therefore at this stage we would be
prudent to budget for those additional
costs of 450 000 for
property about 60 000 properties across
statistically it doesn't seem that bad
for from my historic view as a an
accountant thank you thank you mr
buckland councillor pemberton
thank you yeah i was going to say it at
60 000 properties um
with probably two maybe three food
caddies it's
probably in the three quid a pop so
i wouldn't have said i wouldn't have
said 450 k was that far out actually
um so yeah i'll probably just reinforce
that i was just trying to do the mental
maths
thank you we're all accountable
i'm sure councillor shenton has now done
the maths
can you use your microphone please
council shenton
okay
so
i see no further
indications that people want to comment
so the recommendations on page 87
can i have a proposal and the second for
those please counselor harvey
and
yes councillor
jennings
sorry
can i
check check and i'll just clarify
whether there are other recommendations
other than in the written report itself
but
i thought i heard some question about a
delegation of power to somebody
the intention is that the recommendation
is
for up to nine million pounds to
uh include both refuse
and
the lending for the
leisure center finance uh to be
delegated to head of finance in
consultation with
are you saying the recommendations that
need to be changed mr grafton
all i was clarifying was that there's
some recommendations in the written
report but there's another
recommendation that is
it's not in the report itself from what
i've seen
is it alright am i no ticket
okay so so there's some recommendations
and reports plus the one that um
counselor um
castle harvey's just mentioned
have we captured that
we will now yes
fine thank you i'm
leader i'm clear
right
uh in that case it being proposed and
seconded
our cabinet members in support of the
recommendations
brilliant thank you
so moving on shared leading services for
stratford-on-avon and warwick district
council
evidently the portfolio holder for this
is me
this is a proposal that we create a
shared service for legal services for
warwick and stratford districts at the
moment obviously stratford on urban
district has its own legal services team
uh
warwick district relies on warwickshire
county council for their legal services
the intention is that we create a
single
legal services that means we will
recruit people to staff up a legal
services team to replace
the resources that the currently
commissioned from warwickshire county
council
what you will notice is that the savings
are
quite significant in terms of this
i think speaking from memory
the total savings are 148 000
not only that it will give us far
greater resilience in terms of the
service provided
far better cover and the service far
more tailored to the needs of the
district councils
frankly i i see
no reason
not to accept the recommendation on page
101
does anyone have any comments please
counselor kettle
um mr grafton thank you um
are there any areas
um
[Music]
where warwickshire county council or
warwickshire legal services
um have an area of expertise that would
be challenging to buy for us to build
in-house
um and if there are those areas
would we seek to go back to wls or would
we seek to buy those in for the third
third
party mr grafton
my speakers
so that's a good question and um indeed
there is one particular area and that's
employment law
and advice and assistance so we did a
cost analysis on that compared the
current service that both councils are
getting from the county council because
in fact although it's right that we do
provide at stratford an in-house service
the one area that we don't cover for
stratford is employment law so so our hr
staff at stratford have for the last few
years received a service directly from
the county as well
and we just thought it
that the figures didn't stack up
so the intention is subject to further
further discussion with the county that
the county would continue to provide an
employment related service for both us
and warwick district council for the
current time um
over and above that um obviously
because of the size of um warwickshire
legal services they've got a lot more
reach in terms of expertise
in terms of things that we wouldn't
routinely do
more on the commercial and development
side
so we have options there really it's
always been the case that
wherever you've got an in-house legal
service it's not necessarily the case
you get every bit of legal advice from
the in-house legal team simply because
sometimes there isn't the capacity or
there isn't the expertise and that's of
no
no negative comments about the district
council team at all so we have options
in terms of
resourcing for the unusual
and the very complex
and and let's face it that that could
that could involve the county council
but there are a whole load of other
providers out there and we do have the
advantage of having a
framework agreement called the east
midlands law share framework agreement
where we get preferential rates from
um big
international and national legal firms
so there are a number of options but
in short yes there will be the
employment
law that the county will continue to
provide for us and there may be other
opportunities for the county and for
other providers but that's no change
from any other legal service in in-house
i would just echo that mr grafton that
we already go outside for our legal
advice in
specialist circumstances or specialist
issues you wish to come back councillor
kenny i was just going to say so in fact
um in the event that we were unable to
come to the framework agreement with wcc
on that there there is
easily accessible resource outside the
market which will fill that hole
absolutely at a reasonable cost yes
thank you chair um it was just a quick
question actually um mr golden leading
on from council kettle's question i look
at
risk assessment and on the second point
um or the first point actually 5.1 that
you may not be at full capacity but you
feel by having a long enough run in time
that will give you a get out of jail
card as it were no pun intended um how
far down the line how much buffer is
there before you would actually hit the
panic button that we're not going to be
fully recruited and what's the
recruitment market like and if you
weren't recruited fully recruited would
it be cost effective
to be outsourcing continually until you
get fully staffed
so again that's a very good point um
it's the mind the gap
period i suppose if this proposal is
approved here today um because of course
we will start the recruitment process um
but it's also true to say that there are
a number of risks along the way between
now and the end of next march one of
them and perhaps the main one is
recruitment we've been working very
closely officer level with the county
council and indeed warwick district
council
hence andrew is here um
for many months and and we both are
working together and recognize that
neither
none of the councils involved want to
have that
or want to mitigate
that event but but there will be
contingency plans in place so that if
necessary some of the work that the
county are currently doing particularly
if their projects will they'll finish
even though it might be after march next
year and we also have an understanding
of the county that if there is the
problem with recruitment
then they will continue to provide us
with a service in the short term
thank you mr grafton i think it is
fairly clear that whatever the gap may
be
uh there are processes in place to
manage that and i think it is worth
remarking that the potential savings on
this run to 148 000 a year which is not
an insignificant sum in the context
so
just one last one is there a risk that
this um changing arrangements would get
caught up in tupe
uh yes uh in fact that's um that's a
central part of the report because of
course um
it's these are contractual issues really
so that the arrangement that warwick has
got with the county at the moment is
contract obviously
the arrangement going forward will also
be a contractual situation and when
you've got service provider changes
2p arises and we've we've had
discussions with the county there are up
to four staff
affected
um obviously
um we don't know at the moment whether
those four staff or any of them will be
getting
staff as well i was just well it's in
the room
it's in the report and um
we're not talk we're not talking about
individuals here because there are there
are over nearly 90 staff
in the the legal team so i'm not talking
out of term here um
and um
but but of course
that's got to play through in in its
through its own process between those
staff and the county council but yeah
that that could be a factor that we
receive one
two three or even four staff from the
county council but there will still be a
recruitment process to go through
because we we need to recruit eight in
total
to be fair counselor kettle a lot of
that was covered in the paper
so are there any further questions or
comments member of members of cabinet so
i propose that we accept the
recommendation on page 101 can i have a
second to please
council append
ah all those in favor
take that as unanimous thank you members
of cabinet so we move on to item nine on
the agenda
strategic housing land availability
assessment update council of pemberton
thank you leader
um the purpose of this paper before you
cabinet
is for seeking a recommendation that the
strategic housing land availability
assessment
known uh it trips off the tongue as the
schla
the update for 2021
is endorsed and published in order to
inform our plan making process
by way of background
i will draw members
attention to paragraph 1.2 which
confirms that there is a requirement
under the national planning policy
framework for us to maintain an
up-to-date evidence base through the use
of a schla
and
this
this is the the update i would also draw
members attention to paragraphs 1.4 on
page 131 and 1.5 particularly on page
132 which set the context for the sla i
think
1.5 in short the slar is not about
whether a site could be developed
um
he's about whether a site could be
developed not whether it should be
developed so it's actually a sifting
mechanism
we have to update it
and
members
i really think that uh we should just
then move to the recommendation as the
uh as we have to have uh an updated
schla to inform the site allocations
plan thank you
any questions or comments from members
of cabinet
councillor kettle
um
in the
clearly those who put forward these
additional sites
uh wanted them included
um and looking at one or two randomly
particularly those making my ward the
general
uh review is that they have not been
included for the reason set out in the
report
um
is that could that be subject to legal
challenge from relation
no in the sense that we've got it right
that phil will always tell me that
everything can be subject to legal
challenge but we've got it right so for
the avoidance of doubt for all you
landowners out there we've got it right
don't bother challenging us
thank you for that very bullish
statement council of pemberton
councillor shenton
i'm expecting a a similar kind of
response now
head out to my question um looking at
the various maps in that one shot and i
fully support the the shrub um it
appears that a lot of the sights that
are coming forward potentially
um for being offered
radiate out from existing settlements
are we seeing in your view are we going
to see
any change to that in that some sites
may come forward
on network routes or
um
if you like
more sustainable approach to it than
just radiating out from villages and i'm
expecting a quite a robust response from
you on that council of pendleton do you
wish to thank sponsors thank you leader
thank you councillor shenton i mean the
truth of the matter is that the schla
has to be seen in the context of the
current core strategy which as we all
know has a dispersal strategy so it's no
great surprise that sites come forward
uh based on that current dispersal
strategy and of course the site
allocations plan
is a creature of the current core
strategy members will of course be aware
that we are
already underway embarking on a new
south warwickshire local plan and i
cannot prejudge the
the outcome
of the consultations
however um
from my perspective and if landowners
are listening out there
merely expanding the existing
settlements with no infrastructure
coming alongside that doesn't strike me
as the most uh
most efficient plan that one could
devise moving forward
i would envisage that when we get to a
schlag based around the new south
warwickshire plan
that landowners will will see the
direction of travel pardon the pun
and we'll be looking for approp to bring
forward appropriate sites based on a new
reality
i'm grateful thank you thank you
councillor pemberton
uh do i have any more questions or
comments
uh say no hands up in that case can i
have a proposal for the recommendation
on page 131 council pemberton and
councillor cargill ii did can i have
your agreement then to the
recommendation on page 131 please
i'll take that as unanimous thank you
item 10 allocate
excuse me
allocation of community infrastructure
levy forms
thank you thank you leader um i'm not
sure do we have any speakers on this
item i did have an indication that
potentially the chair of
welford parish council wanted to speak
on on the matter has that
there were two all right okay thank you
okay okay uh i'll i'll move on then uh
uh members um
the report before you makes a number of
recommendations for the proposal of
currently available sale funds held by
this council as at the 31st of march
four particular projects have been
identified for support
they being
the greg memorial hall in ulster
um napton community uh electoral
vehicle charging points at the knapton
village hall
um
some to be allocated to the meonvale
pavilion community project
and then that to leave a relatively
small residual amount to be carried
forward into 2223
when further funds will come forward
which will enable
us to consider
new projects
i shall probably leave it just at that
point um and any questions or
observations thank you council of
pemberton councillor cargill and then
councillor junior
thank you leader
this has been a long journey for the
great hall and i think we've all
got a t-shirt and a few scars along the
way including mr buckland i think we've
seen that thank you very much indeed for
this it is very very welcome
i should just say that
currently
90 000 pounds have been committed to the
refurbishment
work has started on the roof
i should also as i did declare in
interest i am the chair of the working
group hence i won't be voting on this
particular item
but it is moving ahead and i'd like to
thank the supporter and say thank you
stratfor district council for their
support
over the years in this it's going to be
a fantastic community centre when it's
done and i'm really looking forward to
inviting you all
to our first event on the 4th of
december which is a affair
just to say to people with it thank you
councillor cargill i would just add that
not only was the process long it was
also tortuous
councillor junaid
yes i'm i'm the ward member that covers
where the greg memorial hall is situated
so i have declared that as an interest
and support uh the project i'm also a
member of the working group uh as well
uh i just want to also um just talk
about some of the other items that are
not being supported i understand why uh
but do want to make keep it at the
forefront of your mind for example that
the flood management system the impact
of flooding in ulster is quite
considerable i've kept all the records
of various flooding events uh since 1998
of the number of houses that are
impacted uh so i do hope that something
can be done on that one because uh it's
of the order of 120 houses that are
impacted in the town every time it it
floods
uh so we we do need to that
on on item 27 which also comes to to
ulster i'm just wondering whether
there's any help that the district
council could give to help with other
external grant funding um maybe to to
reach
that
and finally um several of the items that
are covered are village halls i'm
wondering whether these could become
exemplars for energy efficiency measures
to their local communities and i'm
wondering whether initial audits which
are the stumbling block block in many
cases to get going on um applying for
grants for energy efficiency measures
and also renewable energy measures in
village halls
could those initial audits be considered
as an item for the climate change fund
and then on the understanding that
they're paid back if the grant
applications are successful and
that they then become
exemplars to the community
uh then
then that they become exemplars to the
community uh open with uh able to show
people just what they could do in their
own homes and that would um would
encourage more people to do the right
thing on energy efficiency i wonder if
that if that could possibly be put
forward and be considered please
councillor pemberton
thank you as uh thank thank you
councillor ginny as you highlight there
are
there are always more projects than
there are potentially still funds to
support um
and you will note that a number of
projects uh there are there are some
there are some status updates on those
projects i think including the ulster
flood scheme and a new raft of projects
too uh to come alongside uh for next
year uh councillor junior you you
rightly highlight that cell funds
cannot be used for the audit that you
mention and i would i would suggest that
this is something that councillor
shenton will pick up through the climate
change panel at the end of the day we
have
a
we have set aside funds
to make a difference uh
in relation to climate change um and we
will be asked serious questions if we
fail to spend that money effectively i
stress the word effectively and clearly
if there is an opportunity to
to pump prime action uh and there's a
the possibility of that being recycled
back in
so that then that money can then be
deployed on
actual change as opposed to audit
and i do understand that audit is a
precursor then that seems to be an
elegant solution for a use of climate
change panel monies
thank you council of pemberton
councillor parry
thank you leader um i just wanted to
obviously say um i'm very much in
support of the recommendations in front
of us today but could i possibly ask
that officers give a detailed response
to those
um applications who've not been
successful explaining in detail why
the reason behind that is obviously
parish councils town councils and
various organizations go to a lot of
effort from their perspective to submit
the applications and i think it's very
important that they have a clear
understanding and response as to why
their application in this instance was
not successful
as this would be very beneficial in them
perhaps putting it forward on a on a
future occasion thank you thank you
councillor parry i think that's a
perfectly reasonable request i think
standard response back i think also i
would just point out
that the sums at the moment in sil are
not huge
and there is no doubt about it that
probably some of the submissions will
actually succeed in future rounds
councillor shenton
just a couple of quick uh quick points
i'd agree with council pemberton the
uh
the issue that council junior raises
should be tomorrow's
climate change panel rather than here um
and secondly i just say uh thank you for
allocating funds to the napkin community
ev
project
from a climate change point of view i
would hope that more parish councils
would do the same installing ev points
at their village halls so hopefully this
will be the start of something big
thank you councillor shenton i think it
will be would be worthwhile actually
monitoring
how well
the napton community's
electric vehicle charging points go
one of the other points i would just
make is that
the use of the funds on this allocation
has been spread across the district
which i think is a very good message
councillor kettle
um it would be very helpful
mr chairman if ward members could be
included any responses to
unsuccessful applicants um and that we
would have the opportunity of working
with officers uh if if there are
projects which have failed
um
under the mandatory uh tests
if we could work together with officers
and the communities to try and get those
over the border notwithstanding there is
a finite amount of capital available for
these
um but clearly
as councillor perry has said
a lot of people have put a lot of time
effort getting these things
in front of us
and having made that investment if we
could
at some point in the future push them
over the boundary into a funded project
as opposed to a failed project would
much appreciate it
i think i would observe that that's
something for members to be proactive
about um
officers are dealing with a myriad of
groups
and then to add another 36 stakeholders
i think you all know in your own wards
where where things are coming forward
and i think actually if you if you want
to be part of that process i would i
would request that you are proactive in
so doing um because they're not all
parish council groups there are lots of
different groups who may or may not
feel the benefit of
award members intervention so i think
that would be for ward members to liaise
with the particular groups concerned and
be proactive about being part of that
process
rather than
adding that and being prescriptive about
it from a from an officer point of view
but absolutely officers will engage with
all the appropriate stakeholders
i think you make a very valid point
council of pemberton especially when you
say the amount of work that actually
does going to this
i mean the amount of work that officers
have done
to me looks absolutely massive
this was a massive effort for the
council a lot of officers
absolutely right and i do appreciate
that but thank you very much indeed
thank you mr brookland uh so with that
the recommendations on page 155
council of pemberton are you proposing
these
i am indeed leader
to me second in therefore can i have
your agreement to the recommendations on
page 155
i take that as unanimous so moving
swiftly on item 11
councillor harvey
thank you leader
the purpose of this report is to inform
the cabinet of the revenue picture of
the council's finances to the end of
july 2021 i'd like to begin
by asking members to turn to appendix 3
on page 209
this shows that the net budget to be
financed by the council this year is
17.4 million pounds
if we now turn to
appendix 2 on page 207 we can see that
the budget for the whole year is for the
total expenditure of 27.2 million pounds
and total income from various sources of
11.8 million pounds the difference
between these two numbers together with
the net cost of the benefits of 182 000
pounds represents the total amount to be
funded from various sources i.e that's
15.6 million pounds has set out in the
appendix
in addition appendix 2 also sets out
that as a result of the covid19 pandemic
the council has received civil
contingencies funding from the
government of 13.4 million pounds of
which 12.6 million pounds has been
distributed in ways consistent with the
government's intentions leaving a
balance of 100 of 802 000 pounds at the
end of july
turning to the position at the end of
period four we can see that in round
terms the council's expenditure of 11.8
million pounds was a million pounds more
than budgeted
this reflects the variety of reasons set
out in paragraph 5.1
the continuing impact of the kovit 19
pandemic is similarly illustrated in the
shortfall against budgeted income to the
end of july of 1.4 million pounds
principally due to shortfalls in revenue
of 606 000 pounds generated from fees
and charges most notably 441 000 of
revenue lost from the district's car
parks
the combination of these results means
that the net cost of services provided
in the first four months of the year was
5.7 million pounds
section 3 of the paper identifies the
principal items of variance from their
budgeted figures during the period april
to july notably off-street parking
having generated 441 000 pounds less
than had been budgeted whilst the garden
waste collection scheme has generated
almost a million pounds 979 000 more
than had been budgeted
section 4 provides estimates for the out
turn for the year in full a shortfall of
almost a million pounds
you'll see that it is anticipated that
the shortfall in revenue from off street
car parking will be similar at the end
of the year as it was at the end of july
at the same time it's anticipated the
above budgeted income received from the
garden waste collection scheme will
potentially be offset somewhat
by the impact or choose those words
carefully that will potentially be
offset somewhat by the impact of the
consequences of the fire at the
eddington recycling plant
section six of the paper demonstrates
that the strain that the pandemic
continues to have on the council's
reserve position which at this stage is
estimated will be reduced by more than
another four hundred thousand pounds
from seven point two million to six
point eight million pounds an outcome
note
an outcome that can only be achieved as
a result of a transfer of 2.4 million
pounds from the council's earmarked
reserves
appendix 4 identifies the council's
current earmarked reserves which stand
at 13.6 million pounds
if the 29.4 million reserve in relation
to business rates is discounted
on the basis that this sum
appears as an earmarked reserve
temporarily
as a timing matter before it is
allocated elsewhere within the council's
accounts
subject to any further information that
mr snow who is in on the meeting might
wish to provide and to any questions
members may have i ask that the port
report be received
thank you chairman
councillor pemberton and then councillor
kettle
thank you leader um
uh
cancer harvey you you you highlight um
monies that are held
at
29.375 million
before they're distributed
to what extent
are we able to maximize any interest
return or investment income on that
sum of money if at all
um to ameliorate the
in some way the position that we find
ourselves in if we're not allowed to do
any of that then that's fair enough
i hesitate to ask because that's the
point of detail that uh mr snowmay
commented on but my understanding is
that balances while they're held by the
council wherever they come from are
subject to our treasury management
processes and therefore
uh they were managed on the basis that
we interest pairing if at all possible
mr snow may no different
mr spell do you wish to come in
please uh i can come in thank you no i
uh councillor harvey is correct i mean
it is just part of the
balances the government's uh paid us
this month this money uh in the last
financial year in respect of the extra
business relief
and business rate relief um largely for
the retail premises but also some of the
other sort of selected premises and it's
a peculiarity with the accounting for
collection fund of business rates which
nobody really wants to know the detail
of if they
want to get away from here tonight
but effectively you know that balance is
carried forward and it is
there is a country balance as well
within the council's reserves on the on
the collection fund which that will that
will have to fund in this current year
but it is you know it is just an
accounting issue really as to why it's
showing as a has to be shown as a within
our reserves there
in short no real opportunity to
to make a turn on that
sorry can i just clarify that i thought
what you said mr harvey was that
that just goes into a pot that he's uh
that is managed by our treasury function
what we cannot spend it other than the
purpose for which it was received
having said that while we hold it it
forms part of our cash balances and
it'll be managed on an interest rate
bearing basis to the extent that we can
i don't think there are contradictory
statements there no i think that i think
that they're playing statements we're
all accountants now fine
chris
councillor kettle did you want to come
in
thank you mr chairman uh i mean three
points
um
one is um on page 209 we talk about um
current budgets and adjustments is this
not now a redundant sheet of paper
because
i think some
years ago we agreed that once the budget
was set the budget was set
and therefore there should really be no
amendments to budget
um because otherwise what's the point in
the setting budget that's point one
point two is um
is there any
opportunity for further
covered funds to be released to us from
central government
um because no doubt there will be
covered costs going on
um
we have no idea what's going to happen
this winter
um but do you have any any
uh foresight is what might happen there
and i think the third point is the um
probably the the bigger one
is on page 207
uh you've highlighted that expensive is
uh we've got a period for variance of of
1 million
uh and 28 000
uh on a budget or at that stage
of about 10.8
million for expenditure which is a 10
overrun
um
what prospect is there
of that
million pound
overrun on expenditure
uh being clawed back over the remaining
eight months of the
of the year or are we going to see a
continual
um
run rate in that sort of ilk if we
ignore
the impact of the
blue uh the blue bin recycling costs
which clearly are an extraordinary item
and one which none of us have
anticipated
um
two months ago four months ago or any
other time
thank you
councillor kettle councillor harvey do
you wish to respond to those
or is this one for mr snow
uh i
i'll deal with the first one
now given that you've got a um a piece
of paper which uh one number is repeated
three times and there are three and
there are two two naughts which are
repeated i suspect cancer kettle might
be right but there might be different
circumstances
where um which could arise where
uh mr snow might say to the contrary but
i will leave questions to the question
of whether there's more money likely to
come from government for covid
and uh
i believe that one too
mr snoke um i think there's an
explanation on point three that
uh the the
the the forecast is that the current
shortfall
of a million pounds will be carried to
the end of the year that's the
expectation of officers as i understand
it
but
mr snow may no different
looking at your crystal ball do you
think there will be any more money
coming from government for kobe
right if i could just uh take those
points in turn thank you i mean just
getting to the first point about the
of the appendix with the repeated
uh budget in it i mean yes i mean it is
you know
not really showing any great information
at the moment but there is always scope
for a supplementary estimate if you know
if um circumstances right and the
council are happy for that and that's in
line with the council's financial
regulations
but obviously you know we you know if we
unless we've got the funding and got
confidence there we wouldn't be
advocating any supplementary budgets
um in terms of the covered
funding the one area funding that we
still are expecting some additional
income is for the current financial year
for the first three months of year of
the year in terms of the sort of fees
and charges compensation scheme so a
claim will have to be made within the
next month i believe
reflecting the first quarter where we
can argue that due to um
[Music]
you know the results of kobe that some
of our income streams have been
specifically hit noticeably in terms of
car park income
and maybe some of the uh leisure
concession which we we should be getting
some of so we will be putting a claim in
for that which will help but at the
moment obviously we're not aware of any
other further
specific or under ring fenced income
streams coming in respective covid
uh in terms of the actual sort of
forecast position i mean yes we are
forecasting a sort of at this stage a
sort of million pounds shortfall which
you know obviously as accountants we are
ten you know do tend to be prudent not i
don't think we'd advocate being anything
other than that we obviously a lot of
these shortfalls are based on some of
the forecast income streams noticeably
things like car parks and planning
income
for which you know a lot of other
factors outside of our direct control
can impact on that so you know hopefully
we would see an uptime in some of those
but obviously at the moment um you know
this is
based on the information we have this is
the best position we can present at the
moment
thank you mr snell
uh
i've got councillor cargill
then back to council of kettle then
councillor junior councillor target
thank you leader just one point of
clarification if i may on 4.1.3 on page
201 which is the information technology
showing an unfavorable position of 130
000 pounds
as a result of additional cost to
implementing the office 365 licenses if
you can possibly expand on that just
from my point of view please but i would
also just make a comment if i may um the
word prudent was just used and i think
it demonstrates the prudent nature of
the fiscal management of this council
that we are in this state considering
the things that have been thrown at us
which are as mentioned out of our
control so i i just commend the officers
for their their diligence in this and uh
and and making sure that we are a viable
authority
thank you councillor cargill uh yes
there has had to be quite a lot of
very responsive behavior on the part of
offices given what's happened in the
council
the kettle and then councillor junior um
uh yes mr snow thank you for that
response um clearly the comments about
income are very relevant but actually
what i was focusing on was purely the
expenditure element
um where the budget
uh to date
was to as it excludes any housing
benefit of course
of 10.8 million and our variance is just
over a million that is that
excludes any the impact of any income
that might be further down in the in on
that particular table
um
so
what i asked was that million pound
overspend date
is that something that we would look
uh to claw back over the remaining eight
months
or is that million pound overspend in
four months
going to continue with us at that level
or is it going to be
a continuing
uh increase
notwithstanding the issue about the blue
bin
uh costs which are outside this as i
previously mentioned
thank you councillor kettle mr snow
the uh
right in terms of the um expenditure
variances yes i mean we would be seeking
to try to recover that over the rest of
the financial year where services have
you know incurred
effectively overspent we will try to
expect them to cut back where where
possible to do that but obviously i'm
sure you recognize in terms of
protecting services that's not always as
straightforward as we would like but yes
we will be trying to hold
uh
you know our budget managers to account
and as we said those budgets are still
the agreed budgets are still budgets and
that's what they should still be dealing
to keep to so
can i just come back to the office
365 question as well
um yes i mean this is a with the change
to office 365
um the council is now on an annual
license for the office for 365
previously
um bodies such as the council would have
sort of effectively paid for sort of
five year or some other period of
license now all these things are not on
an annual license basis
so and of course um
yeah i mean so there it is to be a
budget adjustment to factor that in on
an annual cost
thank you mr snow mr buckland do you
want to enjoy
to emphasize that point can i just draw
attention to counter kettle's attention
to page 206 where the the estimated out
turn position for the whole year
is uh
put at 943
thousand pounds compared with the
current position at the end of
of um
u1 of a million and 27 i there's nearly
a hundred thousand pounds uh indicated
in the papers that uh answers his point
or addresses his point that
efforts will be made by officers and
staff during the year in order to
recover as much as possible
thank you councillor harvey uh
councillor jim
you know my number one question was
about um the coveted funds and whether
they would be whether they would be
further government um funding to cover
costs and income so i do hope they were
kept informed on that but the second
question was about uh planning
enforcement um the department but the
planning enforcement had a 75 000 pound
budget cut this year uh and just
wondered whether uh that it was a
temporary work basis whether that was
the only department that had that kind
of budget cut and whether or not uh
there is any plans to
reinstate that as we go forward because
planning enforcement is such a a vital
um a vital kind of uh service for the
council
councillor parry do you wish to respond
on that particular issue uh thank you
leader and thank you councillor junaid
the budget
has was set at 75 000 deficit on against
planning and enforcement which was
approved by all councillors in the
meeting back in february and at present
there are no
plans to
increase that
um the
certainly the enforcement team has been
reorganized it's got a
we've got a new structure on that
with regard to the deficit on planning
you'll note in the report it highlights
basically we
throughout the covid period what has
happened on the planning in terms of
application fees we've had a we've had a
flurry of householder type of
applications very small applications
that involve
a high proportion intense officer
involvement but what we haven't had are
the large big development
um schemes that that normally come
through
that obviously attach a far greater
fee with them
um
the planning team has tried to manage
um and try and balance the variance
we've had a situation where there was a
recruitment freeze over the last
nine months i think i'll be right in
saying but currently now we are
recruiting and um
you know getting back to full steam but
it was a situation i think through covid
a lot of people took the opportunity
householders took the opportunity to
look to
have extensions
you know to have more work home at work
office space
but these attracted a very small fee but
actually a lot of officer time thank you
leader thank you for that clear
exposition counselor
if i could just come back
i did ask whether this was the only
department that has had that kind of cut
chairman the only only team and perhaps
you know maybe you could update me on
that
i asked the question because it did seem
to be disputed at a previous meeting
that that had been voted for by
councillors
all right uh
so
recommendation on page 199 can i have a
proposal please
councillor harvey and councillor parry
will second in that
our case happy with the recommendation
on page 199
thank you so moving on domestic abuse
act 2021
uh introduction and implications
thank you leader um
i have uh
nick cad waiting in the wings um if
necessary but i'm hoping that i can
make a good stab at doing this one
pardon the pun um the domestic abuse act
received a sent
in april 2021
and
this enhances the provision for victims
and survivors of domestic abuse in their
families
if you look at the
background information
we support
the infrastructure around
reducing the impact of domestic abuse
and we're part of all sorts of
organizations and
risk
risk assessment bodies um
[Music]
we also also there's a domestic abuse
section as you as you've seen in the
homelessness strategy because that's
that is something that is singularly
important that people
have
a real fear of fleeing
domestic violence because
they are
more than likely going to become
homeless and so that has a
disproportionate impact and is something
that we're well aware of
and we are looking to deliver outreach
by refuge
um
the the challenges to this are that
um we're looking at more
people potentially with the additional
vulnerability where we already have
um the duty to accommodate safely but it
doesn't necessarily feel as though it's
going to be disproportionate
um
as our
i've seen personally a big increase in
the number of people
who have
either suffered or survived or are in
the middle of domestic abuse situations
have become particularly apparent during
kovid so i think we're all
ready for
um
needing to do something about it
and the allocation we've been given
um across the county is over a million
pounds we've been given 34 000 in this
current year which
probably i should jump up and down about
and see whether we can get some more
money and i probably will
um it but to start with it's developing
the strategy for safe accommodation
um
and to procure and because we'll be
doing it across more next rickshaw there
are um that will undoubtedly mean that
we
save money as we do it doing it together
um
[Music]
the
there is a financial implication which i
don't normally find in things i do
um
but we will secure a greater econom that
economies
with
both
uh districts working together as well
um just refer you to the strategy itself
on page 219 which onwards which you may
care to spend some time reading
because this is
a growing issue and i think probably a
lot of us as counsellors see um
i don't think i can be the only one so
um having said that i the
recommendations are the contents of the
report are noted
and that the approach including the safe
accommodation strategy which you can see
um
is
supported thirdly in order to gain
procurement efficiencies and economies
that the principal safe accommodation
duty funding may be pooled with other
workshop authorities
should be approved and that finally we
will sign a number of memorandum of
understanding with the
mhclg
that we should agree to that
i would ask that uh we agree those
recommendations thank you
thank you councillor market council
o'donnell
thank you chair um council blocker just
a couple of questions really and i'm
sure um
this this is this is a welcome addition
isn't it to the legislation involved in
protecting our most vulnerable within
our community and it's it's obviously
very nuanced and detailed which is
welcome
um just a couple of questions it might
be they might be crystal ball questions
but looking at paragraph three or
section three let's say there might be a
small uplift do you have any idea given
insight you have within your ward and
reports you may have had from other
councillors what level of small uplift
that might be capacity wise what we
might be looking at
um and i simply ask that because
obviously the 34 000
isn't a huge amount of money and
relief to hear you'll be jumping up and
down to get more um what would the
timeline be on that
and
when we're looking at the challenges
ahead obviously we're looking at a
talented team of officers who are
already stretched and we're looking to
upskill
we're looking to upskill at pace and a
tight timeline how confident are you
with regards to the capacity within the
teams for this especially given the
extra load involved
from a mental health perspective of
working within this field the extra
strain involved in that
um so those are the questions really and
when we talked about um
the money it's about whether we do think
that's actually anywhere in the ballpark
of what we will need as an authority to
help support our most runnable
thank you
thank you um as you know i always just
popping down for more money only being
slightly facetious i mean most of that
is the is the money in in fact to um
fund
the
working together um situation not
necessarily to fund housing itself
we do have we undoubtedly have some
incredible talent one of them or two of
them i can't see because my glasses are
failing me are sitting there on teens at
the moment and i have every confidence
in them um actually being able to do
this i think also
where we talk about a bit of additional
vulnerability
i think we already see
a fair amount
and i don't think that the quantity from
my own perspective and nick may want to
come in at this point and say something
completely different
but which i'm teeing him up for there we
are nick if you're oh no oh no lisa's
arrived excellent she's teed up for it
um
that
the strain
will not be any more than we were able
to take on in the first place but we
have a brilliant team and so very
confident we'll be able to do it
uh lisa and nick go on do you want to
challenge me now
not necessarily too optimistic can i
just frame that i think the question was
whether you'll need more resourcing on
it because it is obviously
yeah that's that's the brunt of the
question is given the small uplift that
we might see in numbers given the fact
that it's a far more extensive
definition now around domestic abuse
will you as a team
need more resources in order to deal
with this or do you think it's simply
that it's a change in terminology and
actually you're going to be okay
i think
through you chair if that's if that's
okay um
i think it's a really good challenge and
a very pertinent question that you ask
and something that nick and i are
looking at
in terms of the resources that we need
to deliver the service going forward
however our early um indications would
suggest that we've probably
got sufficient stuff in
um
obviously
we've trained the staff in terms of the
the new approach that's required
um and um and we will be monitoring the
situation to see if there is any impacts
on on staffing and then we'll we'll act
accordingly
thank you councillor
thank you that was a very clear response
so thank you for that
uh
councillor harvey
thank you
chairman
can i just be my usual pedantic self and
referred to first leg of the
recommendation and
the word is should be an r because we're
talking about contents
um second
more okay somebody somebody could
highlight my or enlighten my ignorance
the contents of this report are noted
it's the contents that are being noted
not the report
it's an art
and move on
fine
5'5.5.2
could i be told
what a perpetrator services
i have no idea what a perpetrator
service
is that's highlighting maintenance but
more to the substance um
it follows on from councillor
o'donnell's point really
on page 226 there are some numbers um
interesting numbers estimating cases of
23 500 cases
um
across warwickshire
um
in relation to domestic abuse
and yet
um on page 231
uh the amounts of money that are
allocated to tanenborough councils is
much the same
what i would like to know is
the
distribution of that twenty three and a
half thousand cases uh across the county
by by borough or district not simply by
county because i need it it follows up
the point have we got sufficient
resource
um and
if if we have a disproportionate level
of abuse then we should be arguing
clearly for far more if on the other
hand
uh
other boroughs and councils have got
disproportionate uh levels of abuse then
we would expect them to be arguing for
that for their cause so i'm trying to
get a feel as to whether somebody has
actually just divvied this
number up and given everybody 34k on the
grounds of
very little evidence or
if there is evidence that supports these
numbers what is that evidence
and i don't i don't expect a detailed
answer today but i would value um a
considered response in due course
councillor junior but just to say that i
think that may well be something that
needs to be taken away and responded to
uh when all the data is available
councillor junit
it is it is welcome um that this act is
now uh in in
law uh we have i think all of us noted i
certainly have noted that there has been
a rise in domestic abuse over this last
year or two
but what i particularly want to
emphasize is that in many cases there
are children involved as well so i'm
just wondering um whether um you know
how how that is is it taken out on board
in some cases that i've dealt with um
the domestic abuse has happened it's
been emotional or physical
and the
person has not wanted to leave the home
because it would take a roof away from
their children but
those children are then going to be
suffering um you know poor circumstances
uh and in trauma et cetera so i'm i'm
just wondering whether
thirty four thousand doesn't sound an
awful lot to help um the the
people's concern but also the family and
the children that are concerned
particularly when therapy has to be
considered
councillor barker
again um
lisa or nick may wish to come in on this
but if you just have a look at page 230
um
the
sort of wrap around
care if i want to a better word um
to go with this includes
support for children and so on
if you look at the amount that the
county council
has a lot of the
work that is done
statutory is what they is what the
county council does
and that's therefore why the big pot of
money is there i
couldn't possibly comment on the diving
up of 34 grand ish
but it's the pump priming for getting
the prop for getting everybody trained
up who we've already got
is my understanding and nick's nodding
which is good so i've understood it
okay thank you
so if there are no moral questions or
comments from members of i think
i just wanted to make the point that the
the funding allocation is um is from
mhclg
and they've they will have based it on
uh
most likely on homeless statistics
that every local authority is obliged to
provide
um to them so this is a national
allocation
um
and it's it's
you know it's quite likely that um
that they've got a very uh very clear
funding funding mechanism but we can ask
our
our local advisors
for the for the detail of that if they
if they have that um
if they have that to hand
and and and council blue bark is quite
correct in the
on on such a
a complex issue as domestic
abuse we're required to work very
closely with our
with our other statutory and voluntary
sector partners
to try and um broker those
that uh
and and get
a bespoke wrap around service
for for each of the um of the households
that do approach us for
for assistance and we do know that it
takes
a person
um
a substantial amount of time to to
approach um local authorities for for
that help and of course um has been a
housing authority our role in that is
securing either that the existing
home is safe for them and that might be
putting in some um
sanctuary or target hardening
works to enable them to stay in their
existing home which can be better for
the children who've got established
networks schools health visitors and so
forth
or alternatively to find uh alternative
accommodation either in the district
or very often in other districts and
that sort of shows the length to which
sometimes people uh
have to go to to to escape
an abusive or or um
or kind of um
uh
partner that will will find them where
you know try and find them wherever they
are so i think this is this kind of this
strategy begins to draw those those
different aspects together um but thank
you for the questions well certainly
nick nick and i will certainly go away
and bring back a response to those thank
you very much
thank you for that very clear exposition
so we've got a very complex issue
and this is just the start of a process
and development of the approach
so with that recommendations on page 213
can i have a proposal please councillor
barker a second
councillor cargill
uh can i have your agreement to the
recommendations on page 213 please
members of cabinet
agreed thank you
so moving on
uh
there is nothing under part c or part d
part e on block items and these are
going to be approved on block and no
request is being made for the item to be
discussed
so can i have your agreement to the
unblock items please
i'll take that as yes and there'll be no
matters of urgent business i declare the
meeting closed at what i think is
5
18.
thank you everyone